when you combine angular with the
electron framework it becomes easy to
create native desktop apps that can run
on any platform in this episode we're
going to build a simple timer
application with angular then run that
app natively on Mac OS Windows 10 and
Ubuntu with just a little bit of
configuration we'll be able to build an
executable file for all three of these
platforms while still being able to run
the app in a web browser a large number
of high profile companies use electron
to distribute their software it was
originally developed by github and it's
used by wordpress vs code slack and many
others but before we get started
building the app for this video I just
want to point out that you can get all
the source code at angular firebase comm
or on github and all the links are in
the description so the first thing we're
going to do is install the angular CLI
then create a new app by running ng new
and then we'll CD into that directory
from there we just need to make one
small change to the index.html file in
the source directory you'll notice the
base hrf points to a single slash to
make this work with electron we just
need to add a single period in front of
it from here we're going to install
electron into our development
environment so run npm install electron
flag save dev the next step is to create
a file called main j s and the root of
your angular project main j s is where
you handle all the backend logic for an
electron app so first we're going to
import the app and browser window
objects first we declare a variable win
that defines how the app will look when
the user first opens it on their
operating system so our timer apps going
to be 600 pixels by 600 pixels with a
background color of white and I also
have a logo image file in the assets
folder of my app and just so you know
the underscore dir name is a node.js
variable that refers to the actual
location of a file on this particular
system then the next step is to call
when load URL with the index file for
our app it's important to point out that
we're telling electron to use the
index.html file in our distal der not
the source folder at this point that
file doesn't actually exist but we're
going to build it here in the next step
with ahead-of-time compliation
I also want to point out that electrons
built with the chromium browser engine
so if you want to use chrome dev tool
during development you can just
uncomment this line and they'll appear
directly in your app window the window
object has a whole bunch of different
events that we can listen to in this
case when the window is closed we just
set it equal to null and the app object
also has events we can listen to the
most important one being when the app is
ready in that case that's when we run
that create window function there are
certain situations where you want to
handle things differently based on the
operating system and Mac OS or Darwin as
it's called it generally doesn't close
the application when you close the
window it stays running in the
background so as long as the operating
system doesn't equal Darwin we can go
ahead and tell the app to quit when all
the windows are closed so depending on
the complexity of your app you may need
to listen to different events and handle
things differently on a per operating
system basis the next thing we're going
to do is create a custom command that
will build our app and angular with
ahead of time compliation and then run
electron here inside package.json will
first add the main.js file then we
create the custom command by going down
here to scripts and we'll create one
command just to run electron then a
second command called electron - build
that will first run the angular
production build with ahead of time
compliation
and then run electron directly after
that let's try it out from the command
line go ahead and run npm run electron
build after angular's done building your
production app electron will then pull
up a window on your operating system
with the baseline angular app so that's
pretty cool we already have our own
desktop app now we just need to turn it
into something useful and then package
it for execution on various operating
systems what we're going to build is
just a simple timer using the angular
SVG around progress bar package which
you can install with NPM then we'll
allow the user to set the value of the
timer and have it play a sound once it
reaches the end to build the Apple first
go into the app module then we'll import
the forms module and the round progress
module that we just installed then add
both of those to the import section from
here we can start building the timer and
the app component first time importing a
few rxjs operators which you'll see in
use here in a second then for the timer
itself we're going to set a max value
which is the total length of the timer
and then we'll
current value which is the current
second that that timer is at then we're
going to use typescript getters to
handle a few issues that I came across
during development the progress bar will
throw an error if the value is not a
number if that is the case then we'll
return a default floor value of 0.1 this
will ensure that the max value is always
a number and always greater than or
equal to 0.1 and we'll do the same basic
thing here for the current value but
this time we'll allow its floor value to
go down to zero and we can determine if
the timer is finished by seeing if the
current value is greater than or equal
to the max value from this point we'll
set up some event handlers to allow the
user to interact with the timer
the first thing they can do is start it
and to do that we'll use an observable
interval from rxjs
that will tick every tenth of a second
we can use the take while operator to
only take values from this observable
when the timer is not finished then
we'll use the do operator to increment
the current value by one tenth of a
second each time this observable emits
and then we can start the timer by just
calling subscribe on it to finish the
timer all we have to do is set the
current value to the max value because
we set up the take while operator and
the previous method this will
automatically cause the observable to
complete the last thing we need is to
reset the timer and we can do that by
simply setting the current value back to
zero now we just need to put everything
together in the HTML I'm wrapping
everything in a main div and then I'll
set another div here that holds the
progress timer and we're only going to
show this if the max value does exist
then we can declare the round progress
component and add a few input values to
it current will be the current value
getter and Max will be the max value
getter round progress has a whole bunch
of other customization options that you
can check out in the documentation for
now I'm just going to set the radius and
the stroke width when the progress timer
has not finished we want to be able to
show the user how many seconds are
remaining we can do that by just
subtracting the max value from the
current value and then we'll use the
angular number pipe to format this as
just one digit with at least one decimal
point when the timer is finished we want
to show the user that it's done and also
play a sound so to place now
we can just use the HTML audio tag and
point the source to an mp3 file that I
have saved in the assets directory and
also make sure to include the autoplay
property the next step is to give the
user a form input where they can set the
number of seconds the timer will be set
for so we'll do that with ngmodel
and set that to the max value in the
type script whenever the user types in
this input we know they're resetting the
timer so we'll go ahead and call the
reset method and we'll set up a couple
buttons here that are displayed
conditionally based on the state of the
timer and the first one will be to start
it that is shown if that current value
is less than or equal to zero
then we'll set up a second button here
to finish the timer if the user decides
they want to complete it early so that's
it for the angular app that's all we
need to create a basic timer let's go
ahead and rebuild the app and test it
out I'm currently working on a Linux
Ubuntu machine and this is the result
that I get here we can have the user
enter the number of seconds and click
start and the timer starts and it's
animated and plays the sound so at this
point the angular apps ready to go but
we still need to package it to be used
on native desktop applications there's a
tool called electron packager that will
help us do this from the command line so
we want to have that installed globally
and in our local angular development
environment with our current
configuration we can just call electron
packager from the root of the project
then specify the platform we want to
build for in this case win32 or Windows
if you're not on a Windows machine
you'll also have to install wine HQ so
just a heads up on that after a few
seconds it creates a new directory in
the root of the project with the build
for Windows so you can see all that
different window specific files here as
well as the executable file so now I'm
switching over to a Windows machine and
we'll see if this actually works we'll
click on the Exe file and then that
timer comes up as expected and works
just like it did on Linux
now we can go back and repeat the
process for Mac OS this time we'll
specify the platform as Darwin and
you'll see we get another build file
here this time with all Mac OS specific
files in it now I'm jumping over to my
Mac laptop to make sure
works here as well you will get warnings
that it's an unknown developer because
the application hasn't been signed
that's beyond the scope of this video
but I may cover it in the future other
than a few presentational differences
the timer works exactly the same on all
three platforms that's it for angular
with electron if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and if you
want to support the channel consider
becoming a pro member at angular
firebase comm you'll get one on one
project consulting as well as a free
copy of my angular fire based Survival
Guide thanks for watching and I'll see
you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]